so let me walk you through let's get to
the top shall we now the first is that
you see is when you look at the
numerator and the denominator I hope you
notice that each of them has a square
number you can pull out right what's
Quinnie makisi for the degree that you
can see I can pull up square root of 25
what is 150 45 times 6 very good and it
looks like you've got it right because I
don't think you can probably square
numbers out of that so probably 25 the
biggest one on the denominator you could
do something similar but if it's
different squared humble is it 16 16 so
I can write this as 16 times 5/3 okay
you're looking right now I apologize I'm
going to do this but I've no space
downwards so I'm just going to keep
going you know dr. Judah spoon from here
up your numbers how do you rewrite the
derail sorry life is brutally ignorant
and the development follows are cool now
I want you to simplify is that simple
yeah right is simpler than it wants to
pull okay
now half of you rock with speed or half
hot a lot of you know that I can get
better than this because I can make the
denominator rational not absurd anymore
okay so you could for example multiply
the top of the bottom by and something
to fix that I'll talk about that for the
people in front row but no idea what I'm
talking about shortly but if I see
something else I can do
can I rewind come back I don't know an
alternate version of the question do it
okay oh um Leah I can't remember cuz
best start that's kinda Maggie oh cool
alright he's going to do a step okay I
know it looks a bit unusual that I would
do this but just stay with me
do you see how if I given you this
instead of their question as it is there
will be really obvious easy way to
simplify it wouldn't it what would you
do
you just divide by hand on the top and
bottom which gives you 15 over 8 which
is great
can you do anything to simplify 50 over
it you could make it a arm mixed numeral
if you wanted but did you know great
it's fine
so numbers are small things get now
here's the C I don't know if anyone
knows even then it's a surge you can do
much the same thing if you remember how
you split soda pop what is if you're not
sure that the square root of 150 is the
square root of 15 tons of protech do you
remember that we did this under
simplifying third fun multiply them
together I just started in Reverse in
the same way on the denominator do you
agree that I can write that edge root
810 that okay well look now just like
with normal numbers without sense these
guys are a common factor the top of the
bottom so I could get rid of that okay
so that Lincoln is written it over root
8 I guess I probably write that and root
15 on a tip simpler is it it's just a
single said I'm done okay as I will go
forward and mention everyone I can
further simplify by rationalizing the
denominator but pop you don't have to do
that yet so I'm pretty helpful with that
I think I'm certainly a big favorite
Columbus all right let's have a look at
this one I have someone got an expansion
for me try to give me like the first
help me do the first line maybe um very
doing and give you some one plus one or
what do you do next
aha 3 root 2 good
okay so hurry smelled it can you see why
I've done this written it the way that
I've written it why don't you place what
do they come from
it's the distributive all right okay
good I think the larger the you just
said the distributive also what's being
distributed in the first place is three
the street he gets distributed to the
route to and the sick
you see that'll give it it yes yes and
then in the second place the minus 4
root choose us to get this abided by
that whole thing also gets distributed
to the route to NZ
do you see how it gives you that ok now
we can tighten this up a little bit
three we 2-24 Richard those are like
terms aren't they so how many route
trees alive you left with minus twenty
one of them is that ok 3 February 24th
what about what's happening is here I
can rewrite this tunnel how are you
right up that's arm that is minus 8 you
are great because root for is just one
actually assert even though it looks
like a plus square root in it for 18
month a step set up
you may have written it like this those
are both line they're both the same team
I'm just a few earlier okay they happy
yeah okay I'm very interested did anyone
get the last question because I
intentionally threw a curveball
interview yeah that's okay but you got
an ESL is okay do you have anything yeah
yeah okay all right
can he's not gonna do just like we
question one I'm going to show you two
ways to do this okay
when you have a look at it look at
question three look a question - do you
see how they're related to each other
okay so what's the first thing that
maybe you could do I would explain the
whole thing right - help me up let's
have a go Nexus root 2 plus 3x do you
agree that smugglers Pat yeah what's the
second thing / - minus 3 minus 3 minus 3
equals 1 so far so good
okay now if you have to solve an
equation I've been asking you to solve
quite a few equations under the course
of this year so far you can you loaded
my fear
what are you how you get them you do lot
to love the step what's the final
lineman to look like yeah so is
shorthand for can you tell me what X is
there'll be some number and then you can
put that back in and it will work okay
so what I want the final line is
supposed to be x equals something do you
agree that in other words
CDKs here there are X is there I want
them on the left and on everything else
over the other side done okay somebody
get these guys I'm going to put them on
the other side watch I'm going to go X 2
plus 3x equals all right what ends up on
the right-hand side
cool when you add 3 to both sides this
becomes 4 then you add root 2 to both
sides which gives you that how do you
feel now looking okay
all right excellent now I need to do one
well two more things maybe how do I get
the X on it only two x's over there can
I try them until one this is a skill I
haven't asked you to do for a while so
video to recognize them see how there's
an X on both of those things right
do you see so I can turn to X's into one
if I look at those pictures and I
factorize do you remember factorizing
you know you start writing by dragging
something like this you see you've got
two numbers two numbers and you're like
oh look both of these are multiples all
to do this that so I can take out a
factor of two but it's left in there by
the way England it looks for very good
and you can double check you can reverse
it you can expand it and sure enough you
get to it to a planet so what were you
over here what is the common factor in
this case it's X just like 2 is a common
factor over here I'm going to let the
air out the front when I divide
everything by X look at what I do how
are you feeling so far I don't look a
bit messy but those are the things that
you've done
you know everything that we've done so
far you expand it then you collected
some like terms and then you satirize
you've done all these the force we're
doing it in an unusual way
with it all right now I'm ready for my
last line what would I try to do what
but what's the end goal I want find X I
want to write x equals so I've got a new
group two plus three hanging out over
here what I want you to get rid of that
I've divided through iDevice through so
there's what used to be on the right
hand side now what's the square root now
into five and there's your answer as I
pointed out yesterday two people you
could further rationalize that
denominator but for those you don't know
how to do that I'm pretty happy with
that okay I have sold if you wanted to
you could take this you could implement
as a nun
- and save it and then you can
substitute into here and then you see if
you do that's nice one which that has
original three you would get exactly one
if you wanna check you can can you can
set the route choose well let me ask you
a bit of space as a great question
can we keep about the - okay so here's
an example okay I'm just trying to
compare what's going on right now first
I want you to just this is easy you can
evaluate these numbers right what's four
minus two is two one two plus three is
five so we know this is supposed to be
equal to all right let's see what
happens if I can't pull the team
fare-bear
that leaves you with four over three
question mark is that for over three I
don't think so okay so we can't cancel
those when can I can't adult intently on
the board if there's multiplication I
can cancel remember all of it off that
was real for obviously a dissolute right
you see why I can cancel here because
it's times ten times ten but this is
tossing which is adding can take all
those you get get rid not interfere